Judy you've mentioned in Prior articles
that you are interested in themes of
writing a wrong so to speak how would
you advise other documentarians or even
narrative filmmakers to show quote like
a wrong without actually having a strong
bias toward um your own opinion toward
it or is that part of your film making I
mean how how can a documentarian stay a
little bit removed from their own
feelings of showing something or is that
part what makes a film great is your
strong feeling about it yeah I don't
think you want to remove your feelings
from your documentary otherwise you have
no passion to do it the subject matter
has to have some kind of resonance in
you in a very deep way and uh to try to
be unbiased well that's like doing a
broadcast network news report and
certainly that's not the job of a
documentarian as I see it I think a
documentarian is there to express an
opinion and if other people agree with
it then they like your film and if they
don't then they don't like your film so
with the girls in the band what was it
that struck your interest in it and how
did you first start with the the
beginning interview what was the first
step
well I've always searched for subjects
that have some kind of personal meaning
for me and um the the imbalance
of male and female Endeavors in this
world has a great deep meaning for me
and it's a subject that has always
interested me I've always been part of
the women's movement in you know the 70s
and the 80s and uh was very involved
with developing a lot of different
organizations that women that support
women so the subject of a woman's role
in the world and how it's perceived and
how women have to operate in the world
to get to where they want to go is very
important to me and the fact that I come
from a musical family and music has been
a very deep part of my life since the
very beginning uh was another very
important thread in in the tapestry of
my life so when these two subject
matters came together in this story it
was a natural for me and uh that's what
attracted me to it and that's what kept
me going for the8 years it took to make
it do you remember some of the first
steps in organizing the film or going
and piecing together who you wanted to
interview do you remember some of the
first things that you did well the the
subject matter was was brought to my
attention by a young friend of mine who
called me up one day and she also is
from a musical family and she said that
she had met a woman who was 80 years old
and told her that she had played in a
big band in the ' 40s and that she was a
drummer and I said I don't think so I
know all the big bands and I remember
most of the musicians who were in The
Big bands and I never saw a woman play
in any of them and she said well this
woman said that she was and why don't
you look her up so I
did and when I looked her up and
discovered that yes in fact this woman
had been part of big bands mainly they
were all women big bands but that there
were all women big
bands I it really was was rather
stunning to me because I didn't know
anything about this so I started doing
research and the more research I did the
more I discovered and the more I
discovered the more I realized that I'm
not the only one who doesn't know about
this my husband who's a musician he
never heard of any of these women and
then I started asking other male friends
who were musicians they never heard of
any of them and then I said uhoh there's
something here and that was kind of the
beginning of it and uh actually I got in
touch with a woman named Ros cron who
lives here who somebody had recommended
to me said you ought to talk to her
because she was a woman musician in the'
40s and she was the first person that I
talked to and that started the whole
thing so how much research would you say
you did ahead of time before you
actually shot your first
interview I think we probably worked for
about a year uh just developing uh kind
of a
concept and talking to people and
getting to know people and I did go out
and interview Raz personally not on
camera but I talked to her and then I
talked to a couple of other people who
are around because I just wanted to get
a sense of if there was a story
here and not only if there was a story
here but if these women were actually
good enough so that they could have
played with any of the big maale bands
or that they could have been an
influence on the music and that took me
a long time to really
feel certain about I had to really
listen to a lot of music and and hear
what these women were laying down as
players before I really said wow these
women were really good it they weren't
just novelty acts which is how they were
portrayed so that was a that was a very
powerful moment when I realized that
would you recommend to other
documentarians that they kind of almost
dip their toe in the water a little bit
get a feel for the
subject find out whether there's enough
material to cover whether they can stay
sort of married to it for years and work
from there or should they just kind of
come with this big grandiose plan and
and commit to it what do you think is
the best approach I think the best
approach is however you feel feel it you
have to feel it you have to love it you
have to be willing to stick with it and
you have to be realistic about it I
think one of the things you have to ask
yourself is one is there an audience for
this and two is there going to be any
funding for it am I going to be able to
find ways to fund this film and if your
subject matter is so narrow focused that
there isn't anybody who really is going
to put money into it you're going to be
on a pretty frustrating ride for a while
but if there is an audience and if there
is a way to fund it then it doesn't
matter how long it takes you if it's
your passion then you have to do it
certainly some pre-production helps and
dipping your toe in to see if you know
what it's like out there helps but I
don't think there's any one way to do it
can you talk about funding for the girls
in the band you said you started eight
years ago
what was the first step you took with
trying to find backers for
film the first thing that I did was go
to a friend of mine named Michael Green
who had been the uh head of nerys that's
the group that gives out the Grammy
Awards and I had known Michael for about
15 years and um I called him up and said
I have a project that I think you might
be interested in so he said well what is
it so I told him briefly on the phone he
saidwell what have you got on it I said
well right now all I have is a bunch of
pictures and some stories so I had a
photo I had photographs I made a book uh
you know
like uh you know a folder that had a lot
of of the photographs of the women in it
and I wrote up the stories of each of
them that I had done after this year of
research and I went up to see Michael
and gave him the book and he said yeah
this looks interesting
what do you want and I said I want
enough money to make a demo
real and he said okay I'll give you the
money so we did we went out and we shot
our first interviews and we did a
7-minute demo
reel and with that demo reel we then
went out to Major funders and started
asking for money for the project so that
was our first
steps and then 2008 hit
yeah after we had gotten our initial
money which we got from two very
wonderful major
sources um we had shot most of our
footage and now it was time to start the
very expensive post- production aspect
of the film and the uh money crunch of
2008 hit and it isn't that everything
melted down or dried up it's it's just
that everybody got scared and the first
thing everybody did was tighten their
purse strings so all the
potential people and organizations and
foundations that we were writing
proposals for and that we were
personally
contacting and wooing all just said
sorry the doors are closed we're not
doing any
funding and that put a really big put us
on the skids for a while so we turned to
the Alternatives which are small
donors uh little fundraisers an
Indiegogo campaign and we just struggled
along for a couple years to try to get
ourselves back on track and to keep
going so that the project wouldn't you
know Wouldn't Die so it was a it was a
long and difficult time and in this past
year things have started coming back and
finally we got the money to do our U the
major major expense of the film which
was our rights our music rights and uh
once that happened we could finish going
back to when some of those major donors
you know got scared or weren't able to
commit to you did you ever feel like you
were going to give up on the project was
that ever something you entertained no
you knew that somehow you get it done
you know you can't give up on your your
life's work uh you know this was this
was a major a major work for me and
somehow I knew it would get finished I
hoped that it wouldn't take eight years
but it did because you know we had that
major stop in the middle and uh but you
know if it had taken 10 years we would
have done it so we're happy it didn't um
tell me about the fundraisers I'm
curious about that cuz you also used
used Indiegogo but what were some of the
fundraisers about well we did um a lot
of online Outreach fundraising where we
would just write a a really
compassionate fundraising letter and
send it to key people and ask them who
they would suggest we send it to and
through that we started increasing our
our fan base and our fun
base and you know I would send it to a
friend in San Francisco who would send
it to a friend of hers in San Francisco
who sent it to a friend of his in San
Diego who turned out to be an ays who
came through with a large chunk of money
so that was kind of the the net that we
were weaving to to pull the money in and
then we actually did a a major
fundraising uh up at the Playboy Mansion
which uh U Hefner who is one of our
producers through for us so that was
very helpful so some of it was sort of
Six Degrees of Separation people who
knew someone exactly exactly and then at
what point did you try
Indiegogo what year was it um it was uh
I think 2010 we tried Indiegogo because
that kind of fundraising had just become
popular and we tried every other kind so
we thought well why not Indiegogo so we
went did an Indiegogo campaign and uh we
asked for
$115,000 and um we got it but I got to
tell you that was hard money to raise I
think everybody has this notion that you
go on Indiegogo and there's hundreds of
people out there who want to fund films
and no mostly it's your friends and
their friends and it's re it's intense
work and then you have to give gifts to
everybody you know everybody does it for
perks and so it's very intensive so did
it almost feel like a full-time job oh
it was a fulltime job yes yes the
Indiegogo campaign took us three months
to fulfill everything and to you know to
raise all the money and then fulfill all
the obligations that we had promised we
had promised people t-shirts and posters
and things like that and then we had to
mail all that out it was it was very
intensive so do you remember what you
did on a daily basis during the actual
live campaign was it was it again more
emails to people and sharing the link
where they emails phone calls um I had a
lot of lunches I met with a lot of
people who uh were interested but wanted
to kind of have a personal contact it's
a very personal business fundraising for
something like this and you never know
who's going to lead you to somebody else
you know you have drinks with somebody
and you think they're going to give you
$10,000 and they never come through with
anything and then 3 months later they
send a friend your way who gives you
$10,000 so it's not it's not a direct
science that's for sure what would you
recommend to another filmmaker who's
considering launching a crowdfunding
campaign that has a beautiful project
but maybe they don't have the contacts
maybe they don't know that many people
or some of the people that they know
aren't able to give would you how would
you advise them to gauge what Their
audience
is you know I that's a a question that I
really don't have an answer for um my
experience with
Indiegogo was very personal to me and I
know that the people who gave on
Indiegogo were all somehow personally
linked to me um I think there's a bit of
a fantasy out there right now that you
can just go on to uh Kickstarter or
Indiegogo and put your project up there
and people will come
seeking you but I don't think that
really happens I think it's
really a dirty down in the dirt hard
struggle if somebody knows different
than me I'd like to hear from them but
that's the way I perceive it would you
advise someone who's maybe failed at
crowdfunding to kind of dust themselves
off often regroup and try again because
so many people I think they become and
understandably you're hurt you're upset
hey my campaign failed and then you shy
away from it would you advise people to
just get back on the horse and try it
again and give it some time well I think
that any Pursuit that you do in life is
filled with failures and successes and
you often learn more from your failures
than your success so um you know of
course you have to pick yourself up what
else you going to lie in the dirt the
the rest of your life it's not an
option Judy your experience with
crowdfunding was back in 2010 when it
was still sort of a
novelty your thoughts now that it's
passed you were successful you raised
what
15,000 what your thoughts on it now that
it's passed well the time it took the
intensity of it I had three people
working on
it for 3 months the
$155,000 probably just barely paid our
salary during those months or their
salaries cuz I didn't take a salary it
paid their salaries during those months
and left some money for us to stay
operating I think now looking back on it
because it might have been fairly new at
that time and people weren't familiar
with it we were educating our fan base
as to what it was um I think my time
might have been better used just going
knocking on doors the way I had been
doing and I probably could have raised
at least that much uh maybe today it's
different maybe people know more about
what these crowdfunding sources are and
are more willing but then I I felt I
could have used my time better frankly
right now everything's you know on
Twitter or on Facebook Hey look at my
link and that's great that's that's how
things spread these days and spread very
quickly but you think the sort of the
old way of just going and seeing someone
face to face
is the power of that is I I think on in
certain areas that's true there are
certain people at a certain level of
success that you do have to engage
oneon-one I think there's nothing wrong
with getting your word out there to
massive audiences on Twitter and
Facebook and all of that I think all of
that stuff is important for a filmmaker
um but you can't ever replace that
sitting down with somebody and looking
them in the eye and saying I need this
or my film will not be
completed and you know touching them on
a heart level so that they write that
check out and I think maybe if you're
new in this business and you're young
and you don't have those social skills
that's something you're going to need to
work on because you need to be a
well-rounded fundraiser I hate to say
that you need to be a well-rounded
filmmaker and part of it is having human
interaction well especially too for
people that are used to dealing with
computers and some say that younger
Generations lack that social skill you
know whether it's true or not how would
someone learn that that that's a great
it's almost like um people that are in
development and and and you know
fundraising and all that where do you go
to learn those skills sort of the cing
that goes on with getting to know some
it's really helpful to have a mentor
if you find somebody in the business who
has been there done that who's gone down
those roads they can help you and and
it's really important to get that help
um I know that even myself with all the
experience that I've had in the business
my executive producer Mike Green who
gave me the first money is a man who has
operated on such high levels in the
business and in the industry that the
skills that he showed me while I was
making this film were invaluable to me
and then just the other day a young
filmmaker who volunteered to do some
work for us while we were in New York
screening at Lincoln Center uh she was
telling me about a problem that she was
having on a film that she was doing and
she asked me if I thought it would be a
good idea for her to confront the person
at a major Studio face to to face who
was giving her
trouble and I was able to say to her you
know what you're going to do is going to
alienate you and that person and is not
going to further your work in any way it
may bring you momentary
satisfaction but is that what you're
looking for maybe you need to rethink
this whole
thing and so I was able to share
something with her that I have learned
and I think that's what we all have to
do for each other all filmmakers have to
Mentor other
people so your advice to her was to
maybe handle it in a different way maybe
more graciously not only more graciously
but to look at what she was in pursuit
of and to look what her other options
were and to see why it is that she
wanted to confront this person and what
she was going to get out of it to just
really think about her position because
it's a very small business and going out
there and alienating people in positions
that you are going to come across again
as you climb the ladder is never a good
idea you know we all make mistakes along
the way and we all pay for
them how did Hugh Hefner become involved
with the project is he co-producer or
he's now the prod a producer we upped
him from co-producer to producer when he
came through with all our uh uh music
rights in the end very nice yes the
balance of what was owed on the music
rights he picked up and allowed us to
finish the film um we first got involved
with him when um after Mike Green did
the original um funded the original 7
minutes I was sending it out to Major
people in the industry and one of the
people I sent it to was Herb Albert who
had funded uh my Blacklist film
partially funded that and so I told him
I was doing another documentary and
would he be interested and he took a
look at the 7 minutes and called me and
said um we will give you a matching
Grant so he did a very generous matching
Grant and uh then I had to go out I had
one year to match it and then he went
out and um I had to go out and get the
matching money so uh I didn't know where
I was going to get matching grant for
$75,000 so but I was on the board of the
Ida and Sandra Rous who was the U the
then executive of the Ida board uh I
asked her you know you've been around
this a long time who do you think might
be interested in funding this and she
said you know you Hefner M because he's
got this big jazz festival and he
certainly loves women so uh he seems
like a natural and she put me in touch
with his associate who uh dick Rosen was
swag who brought the project to he and
they immediately came on board so that
was sorry the fundraiser that you did
how how did that happen and it was at
the Playboy yes well uh when we got to
the point where we had to raise the
money for our Music
rights I just didn't know which way to
turn so I called dick up and I said
listen we need to do some kind of
fundraiser to uh raise the money for the
music rights and do you think that he
might be willing to do something up at
the mench and I mean after all he is the
co-producer he was just co-producer at
that time and he said well let me ask
him and of course have said yes we went
up there and we did a fundraiser and uh
in a small theater they he had there and
we raised about half the music
rights and um then at the end I had to
start going out and beating on the other
doors again and trying to get the rest
of the music rides and so one of the
doors that I beat on was halfs again I I
think I sent out an email to my top 10
funders and said this is the letter I
hoped I never would have to send you but
we now are at a stopping place we cannot
release the film until we pay for the
music rides
and then a couple of people came back to
me with something and then he came in
and said all right how much more do you
need and I told him and he said okay
we'll cover it and he did and voila we
were on our way so now he's the producer
we can't thank him enough he's been so
wonderful so
supportive and you know has never had
any kind of hand on never had had
anything told us anything to do with the
film just you know go make your film so
that's the best best kind of partner you
could have going back to when you did
the fundraiser what were some of the
first steps to organize it what were
some of the things did you have food
music like what what did it entail well
the Playboy Mansion took care of all the
food uh they took care of the whole
party aspect of it um we provided the f
and they gave us mailing lists and we
collecting mailing lists was the biggest
job and we collected the mailing list
and send out invitations got responses
and went and had a great
party so to another filmmaker who wants
to fundraise you first need to find the
venue probably and then see if you could
get any kind of donated entertainment
food drinks things like that yeah I I we
didn't really want to have have any
entertainment because the film is
actually actually the centerpiece so we
had uh a Wonderful Buffet afterwards and
a friend of ours Kimberly Bailey baked
us the most gorgeous girls in the band
cake which was a picture of our logo and
uh you know that was the sort of the
centerpiece of of the end of the party
but it was really just uh we were there
for the film and there was a Q&A
afterwards and you know people people
stuck around and talk P talked and took
photos and that's what the event was
would you advise that people send out
invitations through regular US mail or
email no we sent out I think we sent out
a um you know kind of a paperless post
invitation for that I think no I'm sorry
I'm sorry for that we did send out mail
we sent out mail invitations and we had
cards printed up uh that people rsvpd on
and sent out envelopes like you were
being invited to something really fancy
yeah we did do that for that we've sent
every kind of invitation and every kind
of email
imaginable it's been a a real learning
curve on how to get people to your
screenings and how to do that kind of
stuff do you think the art of
fundraising for films is a loss is a
little bit of a law start now that
crowdfunding is around or do you think
it still coexists but it seems like now
everyone's turned to fun which again is
wonderful but I'm just wondering what
the fundraising I don't know I I really
don't know how other people are
fundraising um I think uh I think the
filmmakers that I know are all doing the
same thing that I did they're all
beating down the doors because you have
to go to places for Grants you have to
go to foundations you have to go to the
ne and the Nea and you know those things
all take uh a lot of a lot of intens
work Judy you've referenced beating down
doors knocking down doors a few times
what does that entail and how can one do
it
graciously or maybe not so graciously I
think you have to have a lot of patience
and you have to know that it's not one
phone call that it's many phone calls
that you'll be making that you'll come
back to the same people over and over
and over again it's uh it's a matter of
getting people comfortable with you of
getting them on your side so instead of
thinking that you're going out to raise
money you have to think that you're
going out to woo people to bring them
into your Camp to make them part of your
support system to just get their
enthusiasm for your project and you know
if the money isn't forthcoming
immediately that doesn't mean it's not
going to come in the long run and it
doesn't mean that they're not going to
be able to help you in some other way so
I think it's almost like Gathering your
tribe around your project getting people
who see your passion and believe in you
so I think that's the attitude you have
to go in with
so when is no really a no sometimes I
think people say well they don't take no
for an answer but I think sometimes the
person might be saying no not to be
malicious but maybe just say truly can't
give whatever it is that you are asking
for and how do you still interact with
that
person after
that I think that you have to have a
real
sense
of of where people are coming
from of what's going on with them that
makes this possible for them or
not and you have to live within the
reality of that
and maybe a no is a no now but is not a
no in the future
and and then you know there's some
people who say take me off your list
well if they say that then it's a no you
say okay we're sorry we bothered you and
you know you have to do that too because
you will be bothering a lot of people
who don't want to be bothered about this
who have their own problems or their own
projects that they're raising money for
so you just have to be very sensitive
uh every step of the way and I think
too responding to someone that maybe
does say take you you know take me off
your list and doing it in a a pleasant
way or at least closing the door in in a
favorable way CU we're hurt you know we
feel like oh they don't believe in
us I don't think you can afford to be
hurt you you're your personal feelings
have got to be left on the doorstep
somewhere else you are in a very
very difficult and dynamic situation
when you're fundraising and there really
is no room for personal feelings of hurt
or
rejection that's you got to just get rid
of that it's not useful to you in any
way this is just a job you're doing and
you won't be successful at every phase
of it but overall you will be successful
and that's what you look for and that
same notion would apply as well to
actually just being in the business
whether you're an actor filmmaker
composer what have you right yes it is
not an easy
business and if you Dev someone I forget
where I read this said to develop rhino
skin where just stuff just doesn't
affect you anymore was that something
that you were able to do over a course
of time or were you always pretty thick
skinned no no I was not thick skinned I
was your your typical uh fragile young
girl who was easily
hurt uh but you know you you learn you
get out there and you tough it out and
you learn and and that's what you do and
then all of a sudden you wake up one day
and say Hey you know that doesn't bother
me anymore I don't care who are
they you know you're you're who you are
and that's that's what you're searching
for all the time and once you find that
once you find your own personal strength
nobody can shake that I have a little
sign that I put on my computer that
another producer said I found it in I
don't know some magazine said if anyone
says no to you and you're discouraged
for one second you're
dead Okay meaning I cannot indulge
myself in any kind of uh self-pity
whatsoever I got too many other people
to talk to who are going to say
yes that has been a real help for
me Judy I understand you were part of
the afi's uh directing workshop for
women yes where were you in your life
when you first walked in those stors um
I had been an actress for about 12 years
and I had had a moderate moderately
successful career but at some point it
was not satisfying to me artistically
because the kind of roles the work that
I was doing was never anything that
artistically satisfied me except some
stuff that I did in the theater and um
one day A A friend of mine called me up
I I was on a woman's committee at the
Screen Actors Guild and another woman on
the committee called me up and said that
her husband was doing a um a film shoot
and needed an assistant and did I know
anybody because I had a young son at the
time she thought maybe my son would want
to be an assistant and she said you did
I know any anybody who would want to be
a a production assistant and I said yes
me and she said you I said yeah I want
to try getting on the other side of the
camera to see what's going on there so I
took that job and they hired me to be a
a production assistant for this
commercial company and at that time I
said this is where I want to be I don't
want to be on the other side of the
camera this is where I feel creative I
feel energetic I love what I'm doing
doing I feel like myself and at that
time the uh AFI had just started to do
the directing workshop for
women and um another friend of mine was
doing a project there she had been
accepted into the workshop Lenor Deen
and she needed an assistant to help on
her film and I said yeah I'd like to do
that so I helped her uh get her film
made and once I was done with that I
said oh this is great I want to be in
this
program and at that time they were
taking mainly people who were already
successful in the industry women who had
writing careers or who had directed on
Broadway or who were stars they had a
lot of well-known actresses an boft and
Joanne Woodward and people like that
were in the program but I applied to the
program and I didn't get in but what I
got was on the wait list in case
somebody dropped out there were like
three of us on the wait list and about 3
months into the program uh somebody
dropped out a writer dropped out of the
program and they called me and said
Judy you want to be in the program
you're in and I said this is this is it
here I
am and so that's how I got into the
program what were some of the basic
things they taught you I've heard that
AFI has a very distinct style but I
could be wrong that was just a couple
things I'd read but what were some of
the things that they taught you and that
were different maybe from other places
that you've at that point there was very
little
instruction what you did was spend a day
with a technician who taught you how to
plug in all your equipment who taught
you how to run an editing system and at
that time we were editing in one inch
large editing and um I had I had done a
radio show before and so I had edited
tape before I had edited the little
quarter inch audio tape and I was pretty
skilled at it so uh when we got to
editing the 1-in tape that was great I
loved that and um I would never forget
he gave us instruction and he said just
think of
electronics as electronic
Plumbing you plug a thing in here the
current goes in there you plug it in
there the current goes there there it's
just like water running through pipes
and for some reason that weird
description served me great it really
made me understand that it was nothing
mysterious that it was very simple and I
just seemed to have an affinity for it
and that was basically all the
instruction we got then after that they
gave you the equipment they gave you a
small amount of money and they gave you
access to everything at AFI and you went
out and made your
film and it was you know they threw you
out out of the nest and you flew or you
didn't but fortunately I flew did they
have any type of guide come with you um
no you learn how to use it and there you
go you got yourself a producer who you
worked with and you struggled you made
mistakes and and and you did it right
and you did it wrong WR and you were
free to do whatever you wanted it may be
different now I think now there's a lot
more guidance goes on I know there's a
whole intense month that the women put
in with classes and trainings uh my
associate producer Aaron Lee is now in
the program and I know she's just come
through a really intensive month of
training but the difference in the
program now is they don't give you any
money they make you go out and raise
your money I think on Kickstarter so you
know the world has changed for the
better and for the worse what time
period uh were you looking at from the
moment that you started once the wait
list fixed you know uh what time period
uh in the in the program in the program
it's a year oh it's a year it's a year
program they because they bring in a
whole new group every year so you have a
year in the program to do whatever
you're going to do and is this a short
film short film yes right and they let
you choose any genre yeah yeah I think
we did some mid scripts and got a go-
ahead or a yay or a nay depending on
whether they thought it we were thinking
to out of the box or you know crazy
stuff that couldn't possibly be done but
mine got approved and I shot a short
film and then do they have a screening
yes they have screening they have a
screening every year of all the films of
all the women that are in the program
and uh it's it's a it's wonderful to see
how many women are getting a shot
because one of the things
about being a filmmaker is you have to
practice you have to practice your
skills and it's not you know like
picking up a guitar and you sit in the
room by yourself you you need a whole
crew you need equipment you need money
you need and sometimes I would say to
myself am I crazy what am I doing here
but if you're driven you can't help it
you're crazy anyway do you remember some
of the first days that when you sort of
quote out of the nest with the camera
some of the things that happened just
being out
there not quite sure how many people
were on your crew but just some of the
things that happened
um I do remember shooting one day that
was
like I think a 19-hour day where I just
practically killed my
crew and for some reason I was so wired
I didn't even know how long it was
taking or what time it was or anything I
just knew I had a limited amount of time
and a limited amount of days and you're
really gorilla shooting the whole time
and at the end of it I thought wow
that's not something I really want to be
doing to a crew now this happens on
feature films all the time but it's not
good and you know in Europe they're very
civilized they break like at 6:00 and
they come back the next morning and they
have tea and you know but here it's like
work H I wasn't crazy about doing that
Judy I saw a quote from you somewhere
where it said never give up or stop
dreaming you may have to do a lot less
meaningful work along the way to sustain
yourself but you have to hold on to your
dreams I think that's a boat that a lot
of Indie people whether it's music
whatever in can you tell us about some
of the times you had to do some less
meaningful work and how you kept sort of
that prize of what you really wanted in
the back of your mind to keep you
going well uh the the phrase less
meaningful is as is relative because it
may be less meaningful to you
artistically and soulfully but there's
another part of the business there are
several parts of the business that you
have to take care of and one of them is
to learn how to sustain yourself
financially how to make a living in the
business and what it takes to do that
and the things that are most satisfying
to your heart and soul are not the
things that are generally going to bring
you the most money so I have at times
taken jobs on television shows mostly
where um either I wasn't enthralled with
the subject matter or it was was n
something that represented how I felt
about things but nevertheless there was
a lot to learn from it and just learning
how to operate in that world uh learning
what it takes to make a product get to
Market and what it takes to sustain a
product uh these are all valuable
lessons so when I would go into one of
these
projects I would look for the thing in
it that I didn't know that I would learn
from it and on that level I could always
find a way to enjoy what I was
doing sometimes it would get to me after
a long time uh because being a woman
director what was offered to me a lot of
times was um more reality oriented
things and some of them had gruesome
subject matter that I really wasn't
something I wanted to deal with you know
sometimes it would get to me and if it
got to me too much I'd walk I'd say you
know this is not for me anymore but
finding ways to learn something on every
project that I was on getting something
out of it making more Connections in the
world advancing my career in other
ways those were things that I learned
from having to do things that weren't
from my heart it sounds like that was
your Mantra then for maybe getting up in
the morning and going somewhere that
maybe wasn't horrible but it just wasn't
what your passion was was what can I
learn from this yes exactly and what
about times when people say I just can't
do this anymore how do you know your
Breaking Point You' said there were
times when you did have to walk
away I think that before you walk away
from something you wrestle with it a
long
time and uh you know you always have
that moment where
you sit quietly and talk to yourself and
you say what am I giving up if if I
leave what am I gaining If I Stay what
am I gaining if I leave and you make
your decision and sometimes life steps
in and tells you that it's time for you
to go something happens you know in your
life that says oh okay I'm not supposed
to be doing this anymore and so you just
kind of listen to it as you go along
would you give yourself a time period
let's say you accepted something that
again wasn't horrible but it wasn't
where you wanted to be would you say
okay I can do this for a year
i' that's never worked for me I don't
know why I know other people say in
three years I want to be here and I when
I say that it's like oh my God I put a
pressure on myself that I can't possibly
deal with it's almost like I have to
live it organically day to day and say
Where am I today on this you know how
what do I want to be doing do I do I
still want to do this is this you know
where I want to be so it's not like I
say in a year I want to be doing this
that and maybe that's not a good thing
maybe that's why it takes me so long to
do everything I mean8 years on a movie
is a long time but it it's more organic
for me it's the way I work did you have
any type of premonition or feeling that
The Blacklist would be so well received
or was it again something that you were
very passionate about finding out
more it it was something that uh
fascinated
me and uh cuz I came into
Hollywood and experienced what was the
tail end of the of the people who had
been blacklisted I studied with an
amazing wonderful uh acting teacher
named Jeff Corey who had been
blacklisted he was an actor who had been
blacklisted and I didn't know much about
The Blacklist but all his students knew
that the only reason the Jeff was
teaching was because he was blacklisted
because otherwise he would have been
such a working actor that none of us
would have had the benefit of his gifts
and so there was a kind of an interest
for me because of that and then um I met
a woman who told me that her husband had
been
blacklisted and she started telling me
stories about The
Blacklist and suddenly I was hearing
names that I was dealing with in
Hollywood as an actress these were
people that I had auditioned for people
that I had read for you know that I had
worked
for and I thought wow this is all like
been dusted under the rug somewhere
nobody nobody talks about this now and
so I said are any of these people still
around and she introduced me to the
entire Blacklist community and I found
them to be some of the most wonderful
creative smart
people and then I realized as I started
delving into this these people had made
some of the great movies that had
influenced My Life as a
child and where were they now they
weren't working and movies had taken a
big swing in a very superficial
Direction you know the it was the the
age of the Beach Blanket Bingo movies
the the
uh the Elvis movies and movies had just
was gone into a very superficial place
at that time and as an actress I had
wondered you know where were all these
great Parts like these women who had had
great Parts in these movies well they
weren't written anymore and the writers
who wrote them weren't around anymore
but they were alive but they couldn't
work and so that became a very
interesting subject matter for me and
again to the credit of AFI I took my
camera equipment and I went out and shot
an interview with this one
woman and submitted it to AFI and they
gave me a grant to start the
movie so that's how the Blacklist got
off the ground so it sounds like a
similar parallel with the girls in the
band because you dipped your toe in the
water you became very intrigued with the
subject exactly starts with one
interview yeah and then goes from there
yeah wow do you think any type of
Blacklist exists today
maybe for different
reasons I don't really know that I I
keep seeing things in in the papers
saying Blacklist but it has some other
kind of meaning it doesn't have the same
kind of meaning as what was happening in
the in the 40s and the 50s in this
country because that was political that
was government inspired whatever
Blacklist there is now that's internis
Warfare inside of Studios with agents
and and stars and stuff like that and it
doesn't have the gravitas of what
happened in the 40s and 50s now you were
nominated for an Emmy Award is that
correct for The Black List was that
something that you ever envisioned or
was that a goal of yours or just
happened because you were so passionate
about the film the interviews that it it
showed on screen you know while you're
making these things it somewhere in the
back of your mind you're hoping you'll
get recognition for them and a lot of
people were saying to me oh you're going
to get nominated for this I know you're
going to get nominated for this and I
always kind of put that into a nice
little compartment on the side and say
oh that would be really nice if that
happened but that's not why I'm doing
it and
then 6 o'clock in the morning one day my
phone rings with a friend saying you
just got
nominated and I thought whoa okay
that's great so it was
great what were some of the lessons that
you took from doing The Blacklist onto
future projects either pros and cons
things you never would do again or that
you would definitely
repeat well The Blacklist project took
me 10
years and after I finished it I said you
know I can't do another project now
that's going to take me 10 years I just
need to do something different and so I
went into the commercial world and
worked in all those other jobs
that sustained a career for me and you
know got me into the Director's Guild
and did a lot of nice things for my
career but um I knew that if I got into
another so-called passion project that
it was going to take a lot of years of
my life and so I didn't want to do that
for a long time I did a lot of other
documentaries but they were short quick
things mostly for television mostly
documentaries for hire
and it wasn't till this project came
along that I said okay I know what this
is going to take out of me but I'm ready
to do it again that was a long
time Judy Where Were You Raised I was
raised in Los Angeles in East Los
Angeles actually boil Heights East LA
man so talk about some of the mindset
that your parents instilled in terms of
work ethic and
creativity uh my parents were both
artists not successful artists because
we were living in East LA obviously they
weren't that successful and they had to
work at other day jobs but my father was
a photographer and my mother was a
writer and a
songwriter and they gave all their
children there were four of us intense
music lessons and dance lessons for me
and my sister and when I started to show
some ability in theater they encouraged
me to go into the
theater and they had very high standards
and we were trained classically so we
were not trained to do
anything uh in the pop vein they looked
down their noses at anything that was
pop
oriented um so we all had very classical
training and it it left an impact on me
and you know when I would do anything
that wasn't up to my mother's
standards she would she would be very um
very quietly critical and say is that
the best you can do oh you know so uh
the goals and the standards that were
set for us were very high and I think
that's why I choose to do these kind of
documentaries that are
sort of large in scope that have a kind
of a classical approach to them that
hopefully will last and have some kind
of impact because of that training that
I was
given what did you also witness from
your parents about I guess you'd call it
the artistic struggle in terms of
holding those day jobs but really your
heart was somewhere
else
well I knew that that the world was very
hard for
them it was very hard because
emotionally and
artistically their passions were
stilted by circumstance I mean they had
four children they were they themselves
were products of the
depression um their their parents were
um foreign born they were first
generation American both of them and
they I think they felt that part of what
they had to do in life was carve a
better future for their
children and they did that all my
brothers and sisters are all in the Arts
we have all sustained ourselves as
artists and we're still trying to prove
something to our parents but we're
grateful to them
too so we were looking through bust
Magazine online oh bust magazine
yes and you were quoted as saying they
call it the glass ceiling but I call it
the brick wall in terms of being a
female filmmaker so what do you think
are some of the things that make it
tougher for women and what are some of
the things that we can do to break down
those barriers or maybe we're not there
yet well the thing that makes it really
tough is that you don't get a chance to
be uh part of the club you know every
business has has its club that nurtures
new young people who come in and
somebody wants to pass on the knowledge
well nobody wants to pass it on to a
girl in in the movie business they just
don't it's you're not part of the club
and if you're not part of the club it's
very hard to learn your craft and it's
hard to be an Insider and it's hard to
get to the place where you can even get
a chance to prove yourself as a director
so that that's why I call it a brick
wall because there there is very limited
resources now that's not to say they're
not they don't exist because as you can
see some women are really breaking
through in big ways but generally unless
you have some kind of special in you're
not going to get there just by being
good or being talented or doing
everything right it's just not there for
you so that's the brick wall and I think
if you look at as a brick wall and you
say well I'm going to stop butting my
head against this brick wall and I'm
going to find another way to do this
that's where you go out and you find
some other way and for me doing
documentaries is the other way to do it
or to do any of the other things that I
do like I direct in theater and uh you
know wherever else that I possibly can
and that's that's my answer for myself I
think everybody has to find their own
answer but that's what I've found you
said you think that maybe it's a system
designed to make women fail well yeah
you know I I really take that from the
comment that Amy Pascal made in the news
the other day or that she was quoted as
saying that the system is set up for
women to fail and that's because that
same thing there is no process by which
you can
automatically move up the ladder and
that isn't to say that it's not hard
it's hard for men to move up the ladder
too but if you feel that you're a really
gifted filmmaker and that that's what
you're meant to do in life then there
should be ways for you to pursue that
and when you get out there and you don't
find any ways open to you that's that's
where the system is is set up for you to
fail right right forgive me I I remember
we had the conversation ahead of time
when we were talking about the article I
didn't mean to put words in your mouth
but we were discussing that how do you
think that the system is designed for
women to fail in terms of what Amy's
article was well even if you get a shot
at it and you don't have the support
that you need in order to be
successful then the the chances of
failure are pretty big and especially if
you come out a set where everyone's
hostile to
you um you know I didn't used to believe
that that was going to happen I used to
think well you know I'm a really good
person to work for people love to work
with me I can get on a set and you know
every I'll make everybody feel good and
we'll all work well together well the
first time that I came on to a set of a
commercial television show I found
enormous hostility hostility by men on
the crew who wanted to do what I was
doing and they had been laboring on this
particular show for 2 years three years
and who is this chick coming in who's
doing the job that I don't get to do and
a lot of undermining went on and that
was a bit of a shock to me
so the setup to fail exists out there
right I've noticed that whenever you do
encounter hostility whatever field it's
in it's usually because somebody wants
to be right where you are exactly and
that's an interesting lesson there's a
select few of women that are allowed in
what do you think the difference has
been well
you know everybody has their own path in
life and some of the women that I know
who are successful have come up through
the inside of the business come up as
script supervisors and in that way
they've built a community from within
that has supported them which is that's
a wonderful way to come in others have
been producers and have come in that way
and you know um maybe uh somebody has
done some remarkable bit of work in the
theater that has brought them to the
attention of some major Maj director who
has been willing to help them uh or has
been an assistant to a major director
and I think that in those instances
there has been a man there who has been
willing to say yes I will help this
woman in but without that without that
kind of Mentor in the
business it's it's pretty difficult do
you think that's what interests you so
much in hearing about these female jazz
musicians is some of the parallels I
realized it was a different time then
and racism played a huge part in their
lives at that point it still does I'm
sure but do you think that's where you
really felt a kinship I did feel a
kinship with them I felt that they were
going through exactly what I was going
through so it was uh when I saw that I
said hey this is not just my story or
the women's musician story this is the
women's story this is our story and I
think that one of the things that I
would like to do is encourage women to
make up their own world you know we have
to hold up our end of the world and we
have to create a world in which we work
and in which we feel comfortable and
there are a lot of men who are willing
to support us I've had the support of
many wonderful men on this project but
it's because we are telling our story
and our story needs to be told the world
is out of balance and we got to help get
it in Balance Judy when you'd walk into
an environment how would you know where
to set up the interview how close to
frame the camera things like that what
would you be going through in your mind
well I I generally work with a a
cinematographer and we discuss you know
the the basics that you want in an
interview where you want some depth of
field you don't want anybody sitting up
against a flat wall and you know we know
the basics
of what it takes to make a shot look
good and we just work around it and
tweak around it and pick an angle and if
it didn't work we'd pick something else
it's a creative moment
and uh you know you just get into it I I
don't have preconceived ideas I come
into the environment and uh discuss with
my cameraman and say you know what do we
have what are our options most of the
time when you're environment in an
environment that is uh not a shooting
environment you're dealing with the the
limitations and so it's working within
those limitations to try to find the
Best Shot the best angle what are some
of the things you're doing to put your
subject for lack of a better word at
ease and build a rapport with them you
have a quick amount of time maybe you've
had no prior correspondence beforehand
well I never do an interview that I
haven't had a correspondence in advance
I've always talked to the person either
in person or on the telephone I always
have a really uh deep knowledge of them
of their career of their history of
where they fit into this story of what
their interview uh what I need their
interview to do because you're always
carrying the story in your head and in
your heart you you and you emotionally
are attached to the idea that you're
trying to present and you are looking
for subjects to flesh out that idea you
know the idea that um you go out there
and you just shoot a bunch of stuff and
then you go in The Cutting Room and cut
it is a little naive because you have to
have somewhere in your psyche a story
that you want to tell and you have to
know how the people that you're
interviewing fit into the telling of
that story so
um that's that's what you come to the
interview with then when you sit with
the person that you're interviewing
you've already established some r PO
with them either by direct conversation
or on the
telephone and um they have a sense of
where you're going with the interview
it's very important that they be
comfortable with where you're going that
you're not going to go in and ask them
some personal salacious question that is
going to shut them off because if you
get into areas where people are uh
shocked or surprised at what you say I
mean that's not the kind of filmmaker I
am some people like to do that they like
to shock and surprise their uh subjects
but I find that if you're trying to tell
your story that turns people off so I
try to take them into areas where they
will fulfill the needs of the story and
um then I just let them
talk just like you
do in terms of using certain footage
versus not using what was your test to
know this isn't going to work it's great
I love it but this for the film it just
won't work this is the hardest hardest
part and that's where you need a great
editor and I was fortunate to have a
great editor Edward o Jima who was named
in the New York Times review as a
brilliant editor deserves that
Accolade um you know we had probably 300
hours of footage between interviews and
uh stock footage and stills and
performances and Edward and I talked a
lot about
structure about how we saw this about
how it was defined in a threea format
and this again is where my formal
training comes in you know I have a real
sense of beginning middle and end and
narrative structure and threads that
weave through and Edward and I talked
about this about where I saw the First
Act ending where I felt the second act
ended what the third Act was and what
the narrative threads were through the
whole thing which as you know racism
comes into it and the woman women's
struggle comes into it and the music
world comes into it so we had a pretty
good meeting of the minds about what the
Thematic things of the film would be and
what the structure would be and then I
gave everything to Edward and said okay
start cutting and he would come to me
every day with pieces that he had cut
and you know some of them I would just
be in heaven with what he had done other
ones I didn't think they quite worked
other things I wanted in he fought
against other things he thought were
really good I fought against we had a
really creatively combative situation
which I find to be the best way to work
with somebody else you know not that
everybody not that your editor says
everything you want is wonderful but
that your editor has creative ideas of
their own and that was the process and
that was the most enjoyable process uh
the editing process was just really
fabulous so your editor should not be a
yes man or woman exactly they they
should you know assert themselves
exactly some way M yeah how can you tell
though if somebody wants complete
control of it I mean how do you find
that balance well if they're not
listening to you if they're not hearing
what you're saying and they're coming
back with something that has nothing to
do with what you asked for then you know
you've got the wrong editor but with
Edward whatever he came back with was
what I asked for and more so I thought
oh my God you know he's taking this to
places that I hadn't even envisioned and
that's that's what you want from your
editor Judy how important is the role of
a
producer well not enough can be said
about the person who's the actual
Hands-On producer who works with you on
a day-to-day basis and for me that is uh
my producer is Nancy kissk and Nancy and
I were friends long before this and had
worked on a short film together we did a
narrative film together uh back in oh
2001 one something like that and um when
I started working on this it became
apparent to me that while I have been
able to be a producer and a director on
many projects that this was going to be
too overwhelming and Nancy came on and I
just put all the day-to-day burdens on
her shoulders she's the one who set up
that uh shoot in New York of the Harlem
steps you know the poster of the photo
that was three months work of Nancy on
the phone just organizing that she's the
one who takes care of all the financial
matters who keeps us straight
who who keeps my head on straight and
then she has incredible taste so every
time Edward and I would do a cut we'd
haul Nancy in there and she would sit
down and watch the cut with us and her
comments were usually just spoton you
know she knows how to just say the right
thing so having somebody like that on
your team
is so important because even you and the
editor you know you get so deeply
immersed in it that you can't see it
anymore and having one other person with
great taste who has the Project's best
interest at heart that's what a great
producer does for you that's what what
Nancy did for us and how long have you
known her I've known Nancy for
probably 25 years but we just knew each
other on a friendship basis she had
worked for a major advertising agency
and my husband was working with them as
well doing the music for a lot of their
commercials and so we met socially and
um we were at parties together and just
you know kind of hit it off with a
friendship and um she went on to do a
lot of excuse me other producing and
when I was going to do my short film I
uh called her and said I need a producer
so I called Nancy and asked her if she
would want to produce that for me she
did and once we worked together I
started thinking you know I'd like to
work with her again so that's what we
did what are some traits that are great
in producers that you would advise other
filmmakers to look for even if they
don't have a long IMB list the producer
has to be someone who is there to
support your vision and not to pull the
film in another Direction that's one of
the great gifts that Nancy has she's
there to support my vision and she knows
how to do it when it's required she
keeps me from falling through a lot of
traps falling through holes making
mistakes she remembers stuff that I
forget it's h you know it's a real
wonderful
support that's what you need proactive
and on top of things exactly proactive
on top of things but knows not to try to
take it away from the director that's
that's hard how would you recommend one
find a producer boy that's a mystery
that I have never been able to advise
anybody or solve for anybody you get out
there have a career and you'll meet
people who will come into your life and
come into your circle of of people that
you will want to work with with and
you'll try working with them and if they
don't work out it they'll go by the
wayside but eventually you find the
group that you want to work with and
it's just trial and error and hit and
miss there's not a place you go we
producers are us you know that you can
just rent a producer it's finding the
right person who you can work with what
do you what are some of the things you
have to do to keep a producer happy I
mean it's like any relationship it's
it's probably a lot of give and take
some good days some bad days well I keep
my producer Happy by feeding her lunch
every day I make lunch for my entire
crew oh wow I do this started out as a
lark because people work here in my
studio office and I didn't want them
having to go out have lunch find a place
to eat Drive come back and you know it's
not like in walking distance there's
some places to eat so I just started you
know making lunch or letting them fix
lunch for themselves but it seems to
have turned turned into a wonderful part
of our day and it's a time where we all
get to sit together and talk together as
a group and you know this is interesting
this new thing that happened with the
CEO of Google where she now wants people
all to come into the office and work
together I don't know if you know about
this well you know everybody's home
working from their home now because you
can everybody's in a virtual office well
the new CEO of Google realized that
something was missing by doing this and
she decided to have people come back
into an office and work together and in
doing that you start to talk about
things that don't come up when you're in
a virtual office and we find that here
that you know yesterday I threw out a
problem to my four people were sitting
out in the patio having lunch and I said
okay we've got a problem here how are we
going to solve this I had come up with
three or four thoughts on my own around
the table they came up with five or six
more thoughts and by the end of the day
we were implementing them so you know
there's a difference between being
virtual and being
real that's that's how I like to work
with my people